This video is sponsored by Brilliant.
Start learning for free with the link in the
description and the first 200 get 20% off
the annual premium subscription.
April 11th, 2020, was, as much as one can
be at the moment, a day like any other.
As the U.S. passed half a million cases of
coronavirus, no one paid much attention to
the unremarkable news in North Korea.
The state-run Korean Central News Agency published
a relatively mundane story about Kim Jong-Un
attending a Workers’ Party meeting, where
this photo was taken.
What no one knew is that this would be the
last appearance by the Supreme Leader for
almost three weeks.
After missing his grandfather’s birthday
celebration on Wednesday, something he had
never done in his nine years in power, it
became clear something was up, and the rumors
began.
On Monday, the South-Korean website Daily
NK reported that Un was recovering from a
cardiovascular operation, quoting anonymous
sources.
Then, CNN ran the headline “U.S.
Source: North Korean leader in grave danger
after surgery.”, turning the regional report
into a global story.
Soon, an MSNBC anchor with 700,000 followers
tweeted the news, and a media executive posted
two candles on her Weibo page - adding more
fuel to the fire.
An old picture of Kim Jong-Il’s body, photoshopped
with the face of his son, began circulating
online, along with a video of Chinese military
vehicles supposedly rushing to the border
- which was later identified as being filmed
further south in Jiangsu.
A South Korean lawmaker, one of only two born
in the North, gave his death a 99% probability,
U.S. Senator Lindsey Graham said he would
be “shocked if he’s not dead or in some
incapacitated state”, and one of the South’s
three major newspapers published an article
formally announcing the death.
And if one needed any further confirmation,
Reuters reported Beijing had dispatched a
team of medical experts to advise on the situation.
During this time, the South’s National Intelligence
Service repeatedly denied anything unusual
was going on.
As panic turned to confusion, and confusion
turned to skepticism, the original Daily NK
story issued a correction: it was, actually,
based only on a single, unnamed source.
CNN changed its headline to sound more cautious,
and the previously mentioned tweet and post
were deleted.
For a week or so, the media boldly asserted
“he’s either dead… or alive”.
Then, on May 1st, 20 days after his last appearance,
Kim Jong-Un returned.
This time, to inspect a fertilizer factory
outside Pyongyang.
In hindsight, it’s no secret how these rumors
spread.
“He had a procedure” became “He’s
in critical condition after surgery” became
“He’s dead” through a series of sloppy
journalistic escalations.
Because so many outlets published the story,
people thought, there must be some truth to
it.
After all, this is perhaps the easiest rumor
to sell.
Who would doubt 5-foot, 7”, 300 pound, chain-smoking
Kim Jong-Un - the man who had a harder time
planting a tree in his 30s than his 65-year-old
South Korean counterpart - would have health
troubles?
Of course, nothing that happened on May 1st
or since precludes the possibility of Kim
having surgery.
Some medical experts argue a new small mark
seen on the leader’s right wrist could be
a sign of a cardiovascular procedure.
He was also seen using a golf cart, as he
did after a 6-week absence in 2014 caused
by a suspected ankle injury.
Although, he has used the cart at other times
as well.
Another theory suggests Kim may have been
hiding from an outbreak of coronavirus.
Pyongyang residents have reportedly been rushing
to stock up at grocery stores.
Confounding the problem is the current lack
of foreigners in the country and minimal travel
across the Chinese border - making reliable
sources difficult to find.
We may never know why Kim Jong-Un disappeared.
What we do know is that the North Korean government
chose not to report on, or snap a photo of
their leader’s whereabouts during those
three weeks.
Whatever the cause of the disappearance, the
strategic reason for silence is simple: After
the world finishes celebrating the death of
a brutal, murderous dictator, it realizes
the somehow even scarier potential alternative:
the subsequent chaotic struggle for control
of its nuclear and chemical weapons.
Rumors of Kim’s death are an accidental
reminder of how bad things could be, and how
much stability is worth.
So, while recent events may have only been
a false alarm, they invite a very real question.
One day, possibly any day, Kim Jong-Un will
die or be replaced.
And when that happens, who will inherit the
nuclear codes?
In its 71 years of existence, only three people
and one family have ever ruled the Democratic
People’s Republic of Korea.
From the country’s founding in 1948, Kim
Il-Sung would stay in power for another 46
years, until his death in ‘94.
During this time, Japan cycled through 21
Prime Ministers, Britain, 11, and the U.S.,
9 presidents.
The small hermit kingdom would both outlive
its Soviet ally and survive Chinese reform.
Around the age of 60, the country’s founder
and then-only leader began planning his legacy
- first considering his brother, before deciding
on his son.
The North Korean dictionary quietly changed
its definition of ‘hereditary succession’
as “a reactionary custom of exploitative
societies” and began distributing paintings
depicting the leader in a more loving, fatherly
light.
For the next few decades, the favored, eldest
son Kim Jong-Il began climbing the party’s
ranks - eventually pronounced Supreme Commander
of the Korean People’s Army in 1991.
Thanks to this preparation, when a heart attack
killed Kim Il-Sung in 1994, power was smoothly
inherited by his son - becoming the first
hereditary transfer of power in a Communist
country.
The question of who would follow Kim Jong-Il
was far more complicated.
He first married, on his father’s request,
in 1966 and had a daughter two years later.
One year after that, they divorced, and Kim,
almost immediately, and in secret, found a
second woman, with whom he had a son - Kim
Jong-Nam.
Three years later, not knowing of this second
relationship or child, Kim Jong-Il’s father
instructed him to re-marry another woman.
He did and together the couple had two daughters.
Finally, a few years later, he met a young
dancer with whom he had a daughter, Yo-Jong,
and two sons, Jong-Chol and Jong-Un.
Kim Jong-Il kept each family in separate,
walled-in residences in Pyongyang - giving
the children quiet and very isolated lives
where they would not encounter each other.
When it came time for boarding school, Jong-Nam
was sent to Geneva, while the youngest three
went to Bern.
What happened next is somewhat disputed.
Conventional wisdom says that Kim Jong-Nam,
as the eldest son, was his father’s favorite
and next in line for the throne, until May
2001, when he was caught sneaking into Japan
to visit Tokyo Disney with a fake Dominican
Republic passport and Chinese name.
In truth, the Tokyo incident was likely just
one more straw on the camel’s back - reinforcing
what was already becoming true.
In fact, some doubt Disney was the real reason
for the trip, or even suggest the arrest was
set-up.
While Kim Jong-Nam’s mother visited Pyongyang
only occasionally from her home in Moscow,
and was said not to be particularly ambitious,
Kim Jong-Un’s mother was highly involved
in political life, pushing behind the scenes
for her son’s ascent to power.
Seeing his side of the family had lost favor,
the eldest son lived an aimless life of parties
in Pyongyang until his father offered him
a deal: Get married and have a child, and
you can leave North Korea - which Kim Jong-Nam
took, moving, with his family, to Macau.
The middle child, meanwhile, was considered
too quiet and unmotivated, leaving only the
youngest.
Kim Jong-Un, to be clear, was not the perfect
candidate - his mother was born in Japan,
never legally married to Kim Jong-Il, and
her sister had defected.
Still, thanks to his mother’s maneuvering,
Un was officially chosen as successor about
5 months after Kim Jong-Il’s near-fatal
stroke in 2008, after which he had trouble
moving the left side of his body.
Almost nothing was known about the then roughly
25-year-old dictator-in-waiting, who, like
his father, slowly ascended the party until
December 17th, 2011, when Kim Jong-Il, also
like his father, died of a heart attack.
Both times, outsiders watched the transition
- first, from a militant revolutionary ideologue,
to an awkward film nerd, then to a basketball-loving
28-year-old with about 3 years of experience
- and waited for the regime to collapse.
Each time they said the country could not
survive without the personality behind the
cult, and each time the transition was incredibly
smooth, and their tenures long.
At some point, one must accept that, for all
their villainous behavior, the Kim family
is also extremely skilled, strategically.
It should come as no surprise, then, that,
as of now, there is no obvious next-in-line,
which could present a serious threat to the
current leadership.
If tradition continues, as it tends to in
North Korea, power will be inherited by one
of Kim Jong-Un’s male children.
Two factors, however, complicate this: First,
of his three reported children, the oldest
is said to be only 10, which, let’s hope,
is far too young, even by North Korean standards.
Second, Kim Jong-Un’s physical health is
probably much worse than his predecessors,
meaning there’s a very real chance he could
die before any of his children reach maturity
- which brings us back to the family tree.
Anyone with Kim-family blood, according to
the country’s culture and tradition, is
a potential rival, as evidenced by the assassination
of Kim Jong-Nam in 2017.
While returning to his home in Macau, the
eldest brother was attacked and killed at
a check-in counter at the Kuala Lumpur airport.
Carrying $120,000 in cash, he’s suspected
of being a CIA-informant, and, as evidenced
by his 12 vials of antidotes, a nervous one.
His son - Kim Han-Sol is currently in hiding
- and would probably be extremely wise to
remain that way.
The most realistic replacements, however,
come from within the country - the most high-profile
of which is Kim Jong-Un’s sister, Kim Yo
Jong.
When she first appeared in public at her father’s
funeral, so little was known about her that
some suspected she was Kim Jong-Un’s wife.
Since then, she has assumed the very public
role of, essentially, his brother’s assistant
- she can be seen standing behind him at important
meetings and handing him a pen at signings.
Many would recognize her face from the 2018
Winter Olympics, where she made waves for
standing during the South Korean national
anthem, cheering for the unified-Korea flag,
and inviting the president to meet with her
brother.
On one hand, the amount of power she has accumulated
and her physical proximity to Kim Jong-Un
is a clear sign of trust.
But, given that Un had his own uncle executed
by firing squad, what looks like trust could
just as easily be doubt in her ability to
pose a threat...
While she does have the all-important Kim-family
blood, she would likely struggle to gain support
in the North’s very patriarchal culture
- making her a valuable asset to the current
leadership.
Her supposed father-in-law, the well-connected
Choe Ryong Hae - is another possible contender.
As a member of the party’s standing committee,
central committee, military commission, and
a deputy of the Supreme People’s Assembly,
Ryong Hae is one of the most powerful senior
officials in the country.
Although he lacks the family blood and, therefore,
also the financial access, he’s had decades
to build and maintain a coalition, which could,
in theory, eventually be used to seize control.
That leaves only Kim Jong-Chol, the older
full brother of Kim Jong-Un.
Chol, reportedly, can be found in one of two
places: in Pyongyang, where he plays guitar,
or wherever Eric Clapton is playing a concert.
It would seem his father was right, he has
no political ambitions.
Or, like all of this, so it’s thought.
The trouble with understanding North Korea
is that so much of what we “know” is based
on stories told by a select few insiders living
abroad - people like Kenji Fujimoto, formerly
the Kim family sushi chef who watched Kim
Jong-Un and his siblings grow up.
With so little information on which to go
on, few opportunities to calibrate our understanding,
and North Korea, itself, usually disinterested
in confirming or denying rumors, the outside
world faces a tough dilemma:
It would be foolish to totally disregard the
few tidbits of information we do have as unproven
speculation, but, it would also be foolish
to accept them wholeheartedly, and risk being
misled, as we saw happen with the recent reports
of Kim Jong-Un’s death.
The next time Kim Jong-Un disappears, we may
learn from this mistake and quickly dismiss
the story.
And yet, when he does eventually disappear
from the world for good, that’s exactly
how it will probably look.
When Kim Jong-Il died in December 2011, the
world continued operating as usual, totally
oblivious, for 51 hours.
During that time, the South Korean president
flew to Tokyo, met the Prime Minister, and
flew back.
Its defense minister was in a meeting when
the announcement was finally made.
Afterward, the Obama administration reluctantly
admitted they were “largely bystanders”
as the guard changed in this notoriously cruel,
nuclear-armed nation.
As it turned out, we got lucky - there was
no chaotic struggle for power and 25 million
citizens didn’t come flooding through the
Chinese border.
Next time, no one knows for sure.
If, like me, you’re not busy managing the
succession of your dictatorship, I’m willing
to bet you might have a little extra time
at the moment.
If you’re going to be stuck indoors, why
not make use of that time to learn something
new on Brilliant?
Maybe you’ve always wanted to learn programming.
Brilliant has courses to walk you through
the very basics, all the way up to the high-level
topics like machine learning and quantum computing.
Or perhaps you’re a science person, in which
case you’ll love its courses on topics like
Gravitational Physics and Astronomy.
Or, maybe you want the concepts in your math
homework explained in a way that actually
makes sense, not just making you memorize
formulas - Brilliant has it all.
On top of all that, Brilliant gives you a
new puzzle or problem to solve every day on
its beautifully-made mobile app and website,
where you can also ask questions, discuss
solutions, and dive deeper into whatever topic
interests you most.
Start learning today for free with the link
in the description.
The first 200 people will also get 20% off
the annual premium subscription.